the time limit for dreams would be like
would be like a time limit for your
family you know they only have so many
years of your life and when you're done
with them dreams are games her life long
and they can be fulfilled at any age you
know I'll tell you what I'm an actor
who's been a lot of fantasy sci-fi
horror and in comic book movies I was
age safe from the Bluefish guy in the
Hellboy movies I was the Silver Surfer
in the Fantastic Four Seasons the faun
in the pale Manomet Pan's Labyrinth
movie I was in
Batman mature McCraney DeVito the list
goes on and on but when I was the big
breakout roles for me didn't happen so I
was in my late 40s I'm 51 now and and I
thought at 40 years old like okay well I
guess I'm washed up it's never gonna
happen
I was working consistently but not a big
big movies and big goals well I got a
lot of press for Pan's Labyrinth and the
first Hellboy movie and then in the
Silver Surfer that all came out within a
couple of years and all of a sudden I'm
out there in the news being the go-to
guy and getting better roles with better
time' log better relationships even to
wit fantasy makeup son so a throwback to
the golden era where Boris Karloff and
Lon Chaney were movie stars you know for
being monsters that was a dream of mine
when I was a kid that I thought I'd
given up on almost and now in my late
40s that all of a sudden boom everybody
wants that so you never know never walk
away from your dreams they're very real
and there's a place in your heart for a
reason and God what kept me going was
thank you was was I guess I guess the
reaction of other people you know we all
can think like yes I'm really good at
what I do
but if there's a lot enough people close
to you know you that are honest with you
around you saying you know honey or not
and maybe you should try being a
veterinarian or if you have post people
they're like you know what you're not
barking up the wrong tree you are good
at what you do and I had enough of those
people around me not just my mom
or not just my lovely mrs. Lawry but
people that are in the business that I
respect their opinions and you know and
every time in over the years that I've
been an actor every time that I've
looked in the classifieds think I don't
know what what else can I possibly do if
I can't believe the showbiz that's the
same week that the next job will come
true it happens like clockwork
almost yeah when the next moon excuse an
acting job will come through the next
role so I'm very excited that you know
it had been a couple years since I done
a big studio film I've been doing a lot
of indie projects in the last couple
years but then all of a sudden
neighborhood watch comes along which
huge 20 Century Fox Film with Ben
Stiller Vince Vaughn Johnny Miller
Richard a yachtie comes out this summer
and I was back in my costume glory of
playing the main alien of the film I'm
the main antagonist for the film
terrorizing their neighborhood and they
have to fight me off
with their and they don't have the skill
for that's where the funny comes in
so and I was doing that at age 51 just
just took a few months ago so yeah so
dreams do come true and there's no limit
or time on it and yeah I've often said
that I don't I don't plan on retiring I
would like to die if I die one day if
you know I would like it to be on the
rap day and I'm finishing up another
guillermo del toro film when we can we
can put a close on a really good that
was a great movie then that's a wrap on
Doug Jones and then I drop dead right
there that's how I want to go now let's
see it okay
you